[Music]
hello my name is ismael you're a
strategic cloud engineer at google cloud
today I'm going to talk about bit query the
google cloud data warehouse bit
query is a data warehouse as a
service it's a service that allows us to
load our data and  in a few minutes
make sql queries with them and draw
conclusions in a
reliable and fast economical way it is a data warehouse
designed for both a small company
and large corporations since it
is scalable from a few gigabytes
to hundreds of petabytes it has the advantage
of solving  queries using the
sql language the sql language is a
widely known language and of
course the data has the
security that google can offer it is
encrypted on disk and in transit and is
durable and highly available
and finally it is a managed service
that is to say no  We don't have to worry
about infrastructure,
communications or security.
Google does it for us.  s
be query is scalable from a few
megabytes to gigabytes and up to hundreds of
petabytes horizontally with high
performance
we have been using it in google
for more than 10 years with
very high data volumes as you can imagine it
is very simple to use and being  a
managed service we google take
care of scaling both
storage and computation as it
uses sql for queries any
data scientist analyst developer can make queries without the
need for experts in the tool
allows sharing access to data
and results with a
wide user group in our organization
including public data sets and
payment data sets it is secure the
data is encrypted even with your
own keys at all times
access management is granular i.e.
we can define which users can
access the data and  how and at every
moment and finally allows us to
decrease  the cost of ownership of your
corporate data warehouse with
pay-per-use and flex billing
with cost details for each project
and each resource
bit query allows you to redefine the limits
of your data warehouse
victoria automates the extraction of
data from your repositories and allows
consulting them from
google tools democratizing
data-based decision-making by breaking down
silos and generating data sets accessible
to the entire company is the initial
step in working with artificial intelligence it
allows us to make decisions
in real time with
streaming data management and  making queries in
seconds will protect our
business data with high reliability and
compliance with
existing data protection regulations
and finally simplify operations
both in data lifecycle management
and in security and access
and now we  I'm going to show the power of bit
query we're going to run a query
on a public data set so that you can see
the speed, reliability and economy of
vitoria to execute a query in
bit query we simply have to go
to the big query service within the
browser as you can see below
, bit query appears or we can write
victory in the search engine
and we  it will appear
once we are in the bit
query service we see that there are a lot of let's say
utilities within the
user interface we are going to generate a first
query you see here that we have a
query in sql format we are going to work
with a public example from wikipedia and
we are going to look for a regular expression
we are going to look for the
wikipedia articles that contain the
google regular expression in their title we are going
to simply process two with two
columns one is the language another is the
visualizations and a third one is
the title for the  regular expression
as you can see this query is going to process
approximately 50 gb and
we are simply going to execute it and we are going to see  r how
long does it take
to process information of this
size of 50 gb
normally in any
traditional database system it would
probably take minutes in the case of
bit query this query has been executed it
has taken 8 seconds and has processed
all this information let's go  here a
shows the result and here you see the
result of our query for
each of the languages it shows us the views
of the pages that conta
n google within them as we
have been able to see we have used bit q
ery the corporate data store for g
ogle cloud that
e  it allows you to execute queries of terabytes
or petabytes in a few minutes in
a reliable and fast economic way I
encourage you to start using bit query by
entering the cloud dot google.com the
bit query thank you very much
no more